the movie opens with a short documentary
about the legendary players of Rucker
Park a famous basketball court in Harlem
we are introduced to Uncle Drew
considered by many as one of the
greatest basketball players ever famous
names like Steve Nash Joe Hammond and
Dikembe Mutombo praise His incredible
skills in fact Jerry West suggests that
Uncle Drew should be on the NBA logo
instead of himself as the documentary
progresses it is revealed that Uncle
Drew used to play with his childhood
France and even won the first Rucker
Classic Tournament in 1968 however
things took a bad turn when he got
involved with one of his teammates
girlfriends causing the team to break up
nobody wanted to see Uncle Drew become
daddy Drew after that incident Uncle
Drew disappeared mysteriously and nobody
has seen him play since the story then
shifts to the present where Dax Winslow
a young basketball coach is determined
to build a winning team for the Rucker
Classic Tournament although he has many
talented players they all have a rely on
a guy named Casper to score points Dax
knows that Casper is the star player so
he regularly checks in with him to
ensure he's happy and satisfied one day
dax's childhood arrival mookie pays him
a visit and mocks his plan to win the
championship mookie proudly displays his
tattoos which represent the 7 out of
nine Rucker Classics he has won despite
having a strong team this year Dax
worries that mookie might try to recruit
his players after the guy leaves Dax
approaches his star player and asks if
there's anything he needs Casper aware
that Dax works at a shoe store demands a
new pair of expensive Jordans however
Dax ignores his request saying they have
not arrived at the shop yet later that
night Dax has a recurring dream that
takes him back to his difficult
childhood when he lived alone in an
orphanage longing to be adopted I can't
believe this documentary figured out how
to film dreams in his loneliness he
found solace and passion in basketball
he had always been a winner until middle
school when mookie blocked his shot
leading to a devastating loss this
incident shattered the respect he had
earned and he stopped playing basketball
indefinitely presently Dax lives with
his girlfriend Jess who supports him
financially in the hopes that he will
one day buy her an expensive car in the
next scene Casper and other teammates
visit Dax at his workplace hoping he can
buy them shoes Dax tries to wriggle his
way out of the situation once again but
the guys won't let him in the end he
buys all of them a pair each costing him
a thousand dollars unfortunately all his
hard work goes in vain as the very next
day Casper and the others betray him and
accept mookie as their new coach brutal
they did it all for the mookie angry and
hurt Dax demands the shoes back from his
disciples but they all refuse the
following day a video of Dax desperately
holding onto a player's leg to retrieve
the shoes goes viral online filled with
shame and disgrace Jess kicks him out of
her apartment ending their relationship
is this real this leaves the poor guy in
a desperate state but he's still visits
different basketball courts hoping that
he can recruit some players
unfortunately despite his best efforts
all the guys reject him due to the fact
that he has never won any tournament
during one Court visit Dax overhears an
elderly man criticizing the young
player's poor performance this enrages
the players and they challenge him to a
match believing that he has zero ball
knowledge but to their surprise the old
man scores basket after basket teaching
them about their mistakes Dax who
observes everything from nearby is
greatly impressed and it is at this
moment that he discovers the old man's
identity he is none other than the
legendary basketball player Sugar Man I
mean Uncle Drew after the game Dax
approaches Uncle Drew and asks him to
join his team initially the old man
refuses saying he is weak and diseased
but when Dax reveals that they'll be
participating in the Rutgers classic he
agrees Uncle Drew puts forth a condition
though he will only play with his former
Squad after Dax agrees they embark on a
road trip to DC aiming to bring back the
old team in the morning they pull over
near a church to meet one of the players
named preacher turns out he is retired
from basketball and become a literal
preacher when the guys enter the church
they find him baptizing a baby his
methods are unconventional as he handles
the infant like a basketball concerned
Dax gets up from his seat and chastises
preacher calling him unprofessional but
this only disrupts the ceremony and Dax
ends up getting baptized instead
afterward Uncle Drew meets preacher and
reveals their plan to reunite their old
team preacher appears happy about it but
his wife strongly opposes his return to
plague despite the disagreement preacher
secretly sneaks into Drew's van as they
prepare to leave his wife Betty Lou
chases after them in her own van but
they manage to escape by running a red
light later they stop at a gas station
to refill and freshen up Dax tries to
ask Drew about why their team stopped
playing after 68. but he doesn't receive
a clear answer meanwhile preacher asks
Drew if he has resolved the issues with
their former teammate big fella how ever
drew dismisses his concerns believing
that a basketball game will solve
everything next they visit an arcade
where light a former teammate who is
visually impaired is playing e
basketball he doesn't recognize the men
approaching him but promptly accepts
their invitation when they share their
plan after this the group heads to a
nursing facility to find boots who
hasn't been able to walk for years
seeing him Dax becomes worried and
claims that they will never win the
tournament with players like this
however Drew is confident in his team to
check his abilities drew tosses a ball
towards boots and the wheelchair-bound
guy effortlessly catches it
demonstrating his sharp reflexes and
instincts okay this isn't real this
finally convinces Dax and so he recruits
boots into his team the old man's
beautiful granddaughter Maya also
decides to accompany them to ensure his
well-being the final member big fella
hasn't spoken to Drew since their team
disbanded he now works as a karate
instructor in a dojo as soon as Drew
approaches him big fellow lays the smack
down on his ass out of anger but despite
their strange relationship he decides to
join the group for the sake of his other
friends with the complete team assembled
they head back to Harlem they are once
again chased by Betty Lou but they
managed to drive past her at a gas
station Dax realizes he doesn't have
money for petrol to reach Harlem he
spots a female basketball team and
approaches their coach making a 100 bet
against his team unfortunately the girls
outperformed the older guys leading the
scoreboard by a landslide during the
break Dax gives an inspirational pep
talk and tells his team that they have
to win this game anyhow because of the
bed he made he also wants them to focus
on their teamwork and Agility hearing
this the oldies get riled up and decide
to give it their best but as soon as the
second half starts the girls again
Dominate and emerge Victorious poor Dax
now has to pay a hundred dollars to the
opposition coach when he doesn't even
have the money to fill gas fortunately
the old guys pool their money and help
him settle the debt they also provide
Dax with the gas money much to his
Delight upon their arrival in Harlem the
team visits their old basketball court
where they used to practice when they
were younger this brings back an
avalanche of memories causing the old
guys to become emotional then Drew opens
his bag and reveals that he has brought
gifts for each team member light
receives Advanced goggles to give him
Clear Vision boots gets a pair of
Converse shoes that allow him to stand
for the first time in years preacher
receives a crucifix necklace and big
fella receives their first kids
tournament trophy while everyone is
happy with their gifts big fella Stomps
on the trophy refusing to forgive Drew
for his past actions later Dax goes to
Jess's apartment and finds out that she
has moved on and is now with his Nemesis
mookie just leaves him angry and
devastated but he promises to teach them
a lesson soon after a few days the
Tournament begins and the team has a
good start after winning their first
game however in the second game they
give up a big lead and end up losing due
to the conflict between big fella and
Drew Dax tries his best to reconcile the
two but to no avail the following day
big fella is paying his respects at his
late wife's grave Drew coincidentally
arrives there they awkwardly greet each
other and finally open up about their
past it is revealed that after an
important match Drew got so drunk that
he ended up sleeping with Big Fella's
wife it was a mistake that he still
regrets to this day Drew then looks big
fella in the eye and apologizes for the
incident saying he would have never done
it if he weren't intoxicated this
finally gives a big follow the closure
he was looking for so he forgives his
friend immediately now with the entire
team on the same page they start winning
game after game they celebrate their
victories by visiting nightclubs where
they drink a lot of booze and dance like
crazy as the days pass Dax and Maya also
become close and eventually start dating
after winning several Games stax's Team
reaches the semi-finals if they win they
will face Mookie's team in the finals
however during the first half of the
game disaster strikes as big fella
suffers a massive heart attack and
collapses to the ground he is
immediately rushed to the hospital and
saved but the doctors reveal that he can
never play again now with a major player
out Dak starts looking for a replacement
since no one is interested in joining
the oldies he is forced to recruit
preacher's wife Betty Lou the team
somehow wins the semi-final and now Dax
is set to face off against his old
Nemesis mookie the scene then cuts to
the finals day where both teams are seen
preparing for the game on one hand the
oldies want to win the championship and
retire peacefully while on the other
hand the Young Gun led by Casper want to
make a statement soon the game begins
and Mookie's team swiftly takes the lead
using their physicality and Superior
Tactics the old guys struggle to keep up
with the pace and energy however after a
while they figure out the opposition's
game plan and start playing better the
oldies hit several impressive baskets
and build up the score but at a crucial
point of the game light and Casper
Collide into the post rendering both of
them injured as they are forced out of
the game tension Rises between the team
coaches after a lot of thinking mookie
gets into the court himself but Dax is
hesitant as he fears being humiliated
again he believes he is not a good
player at all however when Uncle Drew
and the others motivate him Dax decides
to go for it after the game resumes
mookie wastes no time and scores his
first basket implying that he's still
the pro he once was with only eight
seconds left on the clock Dax gets a
golden chance to score the winning
basket but hesitates when he gets
flashbacks of the same incident hence he
calls for a timeout during the break
team motivates him once again saying he
should do it for the team as well as
himself Dax also remembers that he has
to teach his ex-girlfriend Jesse a
lesson so he immediately gets riled up
he then steps under the court with
Renewed Energy promising to get his best
lo and behold Dax manages to make the
game-winning shot finally beating mookie
seeing the game end in a nail-biting
finish the crowd goes into a state of
frenzy and Praises him for his final
shot even an impressed mookie
congratulates Dax and shows him respect
for the first time ever after their win
they all visit big fella in the hospital
and the prize money is used for his
treatment the movie ends with a news
report on ESPN portraying how Dax
transformed from being a joke with his
old team to being a hero of the finals
was it real was that real
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching